今天我们继续我们之前的话题
real time environment mapping啊
大家看到我们稍微改了一下
这个咱们课程的顺序
然后本来呢我是说呃precomputed radiance transfer
咱们是作为呃呃全局光照的这么一块来嗯
这这块知识来说
后来我想了一想
其实呢这个知识和呃environment mapping
其实结合的更紧密一些
所以咱们应该先说这块啊
看这个意思行吧
反正没关系
就是调整一下顺序啊
那么呃今天在课程之前
咱们还是说这么几个事情
一个是呢上一节课我已经说了
我们下周是没课的
下周我要出差啊啊ok然后呢
呃呃一个重要的事情啊
是这样的
就是说呢我们这个课程啊
有同学反映说
我们这每一节课都会讲到将近一个半小时
这个课程容量有点大
再加上一一周讲两节
这个有点吃不消的是吧
这个当然不止同学正觉得我自己也觉得哈
就是说单纯从讲课的角度上来说
呃那要不之后我们就按照这么一个方式来改
我们把课程改成每周一讲一讲啊
然后这一讲呢我就得顺理成章的多讲一点时间
讲了一个多小时吧
讲到一个半小时左右
这么来安排呃
那其实内容呢也不会少
然后就是说我们会这战线会拖的稍微长一点哈
然后如果说到时候呃涉及到呃
如果课程不想拖入6月份或者或者怎么着对吧
然后我到时候呢我再把它呃
呃到那个时候我再把它弄回
每周两节也不是不行啊
就是说咱们先这么处理
从什么时候开始呢
从我回来开始
然后我回来的那周
我们就只保留星期六的课程
好吧
嗯这样的话呢也省得说有同学周二对吧
周二这个时候是工作日嘛
不不太有时间看呃
也就是说我们今天是第六讲
对不对
第七讲呢是嗯在4月的4月17号啊
这这样来安排之后
我们就放在每周六来讲啊
应该是件好事情啊
没问题
就是说咱们理论上来说就是不应该讲的这么快
大家想一想
在大学的课程里面
如果说涉及到这这一节课
每周要讲两个这种嗯
每次两节的45分钟大课啊
这个就有点压力太大了
确实真的
所以说绝对是好事情
而且后续的嗯嗯就怎么说呢
这个呃总共的课程的课时数有没有少嘛
对吧好吧
那咱们就这么安排
那么呃另外呢就是说咱们说课程的课程的顺序
我们简单调整一下
那咱们今天就先讲所谓啊p r t相关的内容
precomputed radiance transfer
刚才我也说理由了对吧
p r t这块呢它又可以做environment lighting
它又可以做全局光照
那所以说正好作为一个连接
咱们先说它好吧
这个意思嗯
好有同学说课前的这些资料多一点就可以
没问题
然后这次我也已经注意了
大家如果看课程主页的话
我是在课前已经放出了大家需要参考的内容哈
呃之后也会这么来安排啊
也可以更早一点吧
反正之后咱们这个课再慢慢的把它
这个怎么说呢
它打磨的更好一点
这个意思
那这就是课前咱们要说的几个上啊
好的
那么呃上一节课咱们说了什么呢
对吧
咱们上一节课
把阴影的地方稍微就算是说完了吧
呃补充了一个知识叫distance field soft shadow
然后或者叫signed distance field sdf都是可以的
总之咱们可以看到sdf是一个非常强大的东西
然后它不只是可以这描述这些啊
影视的表面还可以利用它呃
在几乎没有其他代价的情况下
生成一些呃软阴影的效果对吧
然后咱们就呃变到另外一个话题
我们说如果给一个啊环境光照
那么怎么才能把这个环境光照下任何一个点
它的着色也就是shading得算出来呢
于是呢我们就把它呃
呃就就给大家介绍了一个
在arreal engine里面用的呃非常好的一个技术
叫做split sum的一个估计对吧
大家可以看到
我们做了很多很多各种各样不同的操作
把呃比如说lighting给拆出来
然后呢
比如说我们我们呃
又在后续的预计算的过程中对吧
然后我们不断的对参数空间进行降维
然后直到最后我们可以得到一个可以啊
所谓affordable的一种预计算
然后我们只用打一张2d的一个表格
对不对
到时候使用的时候我就可以啊
直接过来查他
那就会变得非常方便
那么这里呢呃上一次啊我这随口之秘说
我说有一个更好的办法叫做ltc啊
然后后来我回去想
其实我这样说不合适啊
为什么呢
因为我这想当然了
在学术界啊
大家普遍认为说如果咱们能不预计算
那得到的方法
那自然是更好的
那所以说我就沿着这么一个思路
我就随口一说
说ltc既然可以不用预计算的
当然效果应该会比split sum好
呃但是事实是并非如此啊
就是从效果上来说
split sum又可以更快
然后效果又更好
而且其实啊l t c咱们之后是会说的哈
大家肯定不知道我在说什么
ltc这种方法之后
我们会说它其实其实也是需要一点点去计算的
所以从这个角度上来说啊
这个split summer proximation
大家就认为啊这个东西就是state of the art
就是没问题的
好吧嗯
那么咱们今天说什么
今天呢咱们会说嗯
嗯首先嗯上一次咱们没有提到一个话题对吧
一个挺困难的话题
我们说了
给你environment lighting
你怎么算任何一个点的着色
也就是shading
咱们不考虑shadow的情况下
那么真的这shadow要怎么算呢
是不是哈哈哈啊
这个就就简单提一下
用来引入咱们今天的内容哈
然后咱们今天的内容呃
主要的目的就是说真的给你环境光了
然后呢
你怎么实时的去把它对应的shading以及shaidol
都给算的对
然后特别的呢
咱们今天要讲的内容就是一个叫做precomputed
radiance transfer的一个内容
好吧
那么今天呢稍微有一点麻烦的呃
就是说呃呃p r t这块
它要求用到一个相对来说听起来比较复杂的
一个啊数学知识
这个东西叫做spherical harmonics
那就简称s h啊
国内叫呃球面斜波函数
有人管它简称叫求斜函数啊一回事
那么呃就是这么一个函数
哈哈这挺麻烦的
那咱们今天尽量能够把它呃
从所谓high level的一个思想上把它给说清楚
ok那咱们再说之前呢还是一样
呃
我我简单说一下啊
关于这种预计算的这么一种思路啊
在大概20年前是得到一个
非常非常普遍的一个应用呃
20~10年前吧
然后后来渐渐的呢在各种各样实时的
比如说游戏开发中
大家就会发明各种各样的呃
我又不需要预计算
又可以得到一些近似效果的一些方法
然后渐渐的这些预计算方法就用的不那么多了
但咱们仍然一定是要说的
因为他是一个非常里程碑的一个呃
一个一个一个作品吧
然后直到今天
学术界还在努力的把这个方向往后面
进行了积极的推动啊
咱们呃uc irvine分校的一位老师叫做赵爽啊
然后呃我们大家其实都做了不少相关的这些
p r t方面的研究
然后这块呢呃我在想啊
如果有同学问我
那他之后还会不会可能得到嗯
比较不错的应用呢
我的答案是是的
尤其是和呃real time retracing结合起来啊
这块可能会得到一个嗯嗯怎么说呢
一个重新焕发生机的机会啊
我这么这么觉得哎
那这就是简单在一开始先跟大家说一说啊
咱们说p r t的意义是非常有意义的一件事情
咱们不能不能说
只看着说现在工业界在做什么啊
这事儿好了
那嗯咱们首先要说什么呢
要说的就是啊从环境光照下
我们怎么样得到阴影
对不对
那么非常非常不幸的消息是什么呢
是我们不知道怎么做哈哈
在实时渲染下
如果大家有了环境光照之后
然后怎么得到这个环境光照下照出来的物体
各个地方的阴影呢
然后如果说咱们有一个嗯最high level的答案
那就是做不到啊
非常难的
然后这个事情是是非常非常困难的
为什么呢
我这里呢给大家提供两个不同的思路
什么呢
第一就是说环境光
咱们把它理解成什么
ok咱们把它理解成什么呢
我们可以理解成四面八方过来的光照嘛
对不对
四面八方来到光照
那就有可能四面八方来的光照都不一样咯
那如果都不一样的话
那我每一个方向的光照
我是不是可以认为它是一个呃某种光源
对不对
那如果说环境光上有一片
那都是白的
我就认为那儿有一个呃111个面积光源
它就是个白的
那也就是说呢
咱们可以把环境光照给描述成为一个什么问题
所谓many light问题啊
这个问题呢大家可以看到这个名字啊
他是这啊
这英文使用
它是个非常非常直白的
一个使用很多光源的一个问题
他就是这么个意思哈
many light指的就是这个意思
那你环境光照
你肯定是可以把它认为就是很多光源嘛
对不对
那么如果说这种情况下我要渲染整个场景
我要把它的阴影给弄出来
它为什么难呢
就是因为啊我每一个光源
我是不是为了照亮这个场景
我想得到它的阴影
我都得给它生成一个shadow map
这还得了对吗
那这样一来的话
就等于是我我每一个光源生成一个来呃呃来呃
这叫什么来着啊
shadow map的话
那我的这个代价是多少呢
那当然是线性于光源的数量的
对不对
那这是非常嗯非常高代价的一个事情呢
所以说这自然是我们不愿意做的一个事
这是一个看待环境光照的方法
另外一个是什么呢
我们把它当做一个采样的一个方法
这样来考虑
那是这样的
在任何一个shading point
我自然知道来自于它的整个上半球
各个不同方向的光照都是什么
然后我现在要解所谓的rendering equation
对不对
我要解rendering equation
那我最简单的办法就应该去采样
我就采用什么呢
采样空间中呃
就是各个方向上啊
嗯它的不同的光照我可以做一些重要性采样
哪一块亮有多裁一点
对不对
这都没问题
但仍然是需要大量的采样的样本的
因为难度呢不是在你采用光照上面
而是因为你并不知道从任何一个shading point
往各个不同的方向去看
然后你会看到的所谓visibility term是什么
ok这是一个非常现实的问题
visibility term才是最难的
他可能在四面八方不同的位置上
不同的方向上
它的遮挡情况是截然不同的
ok这可能是一个非常困难的事情
而你可以去重要性采样环境光照
这是可以的
但是你本来就不知道任何一个shading point的周围
不同方向的遮挡情况
你如何去采用它呢
你只能去盲目的采样
是不是
所以说这样一来的话呢
这个visibility就挺难的
那么另外一个角度去看待这个问题呢
就是就是这个意思
我们之前所说的哎
咱们给它起个名字吧
叫real time rendering equation
好不好
呃
就是我们之前说的那个拆分的方式啊
大家还记得吧
fx和gx乘起来积分
我们可以把fx和gx分别拿出积分
当然有一些这些规划常数了
对不对
哎我们说之前条件是什么呀
如果能拆的话
得要求gx啊
它的support或会比较小
对不对
或者说它的频率比较低
它比较smooth
那咱们之前才说这个visibility term
这个visibility可能呃挺麻烦的
然后呢除了visibility之外
另外的b r d f可能是挺高频的
特别是对于啊gloy b2 d f对不对
对于这个diffuse b2 d f哦
它是低频变得挺慢的
但对于gloy b2 d f
它是不是集中在一个中间很小的一个区域
某些方面上
然后瞬间一下就变得的值就变得非常小
那也就是说它是非常高频的
glossy的b2 df对不对
另外一个情况呢
那环境光这一项也就是lg项l这项
它的support是多大呀
它是整个半球对吧
我们之前说
如果你要是想把这个呃某一个term拆出来
他剩下在在积分里的term
他要么就得保持保持低频
刚才说了b r d f在
所以做不到
那要么就要保证他的support的很小
这对不起
lighting在你也做不到
所以这样的话
visibility呢不太能容易把刚才的那么一个公式中
呃
就是这意思
不容易从我们整个的runner equation中
把visibility提出来
我就想说这个事
ok那这样一来的话呢
为什么它难咱们就说清楚了
对不对
这是这是很多不同的看待方法
当然还可以有一些别的方法
那我看有同学问这个事情
说能不能用所谓环境光遮蔽ambient collusion
这也是我们要说的一个话题啊
嗯来近似呃
整个visibility
这是可以的啊
这是可以的
但是我们之后在呃这个教学过程中
大家就会发现
他这里近似了一个非常重要的事情
环境光遮蔽
他认为你是有一个stenvironment lighting的情况下
才可以做这个近似好吗
就是说也就是说它近似出来的东西
是不怎么准的好吧
这个意思啊
我说清楚constant呃
这environment来
意思就是说我认为整个环境光是全白好吧
要么全灰啊
这这种就是它不能是嗯嗯任意的环境光
当然如果真是任意环境光
你又用所谓的ao去近似
能得到结果自然没那么准
没那么准
那就是看着别扭
那就是正常
现在来说呃
咱们大家能够做到的一个效果哈
这么个意思啊
那行
那这就是我要说的一个一个事情
那么现在再给大家一个解决方案啊
这个解决方案听起来非常的土
但是这个这个方案确实
现在现在绝大多数工业界在做的一个事情
什么呢
就是说环境光照里面啊
它总有一个最最最最能有代表性的一个光源吧
比如说人们在野外上这跑的时候对吧
那最重要的光源就是太阳的
那太阳肯定就来自于比较小的一个
一个立体角了
对不对
那这样的话
我就主要就生成太阳投射下来的阴影就好了
就这么个意思啊
从最亮的光源下
我生成一个阴影
或者是稍微多点生成了两三个差不多了
这真的就是工业界的一个解决方案
而且还不错嘛对吧
大家打游戏里面基本上来说都是这样的
哈哈哈哈好吧
那所以说嘛这就是呃基本上来说我说的一些呃
它比较困难的这个呃原因以及向量解决方法
另外呢我给大家算是提供一系列指针啊
就是说如果大家希望我这方面看一看
这方面的研究
有这么几个事情是我可以立刻想到的一个呢
有一篇实时渲染的工作叫imperfect shadow maps啊
这个工作理论上来说不是做shadow from environment lighting
他是他是做的direct illumination
shadow
也就是做的是全局光照部分的呃
产生的各种各样的这些这些啊阴影啊
这么个意思
然后嗯挺有意思的一个文章吧
也挺好懂
大家如果可以找到他的paper以及他的呃
我记得他还放出了一些ppt啊
可以直接看一看
应该是呃利用我们现在的知识来看
他的话应该是没什么问题啊
这个意思特别是咱们之后两讲
咱们把这个啊呃全局光照得说明白了之后啊
啊这块应该是挺容易的
另外一个呢
在离线渲染里面有一个非常重要的一个
也是里程碑式的作呃
呃一系列工作吧
好吧呃叫做什么呢
叫做light cuts
light cuts的思路就是啊
把场景中这些嗯反射物当成很多的小的
这些光源
那当然很多反射物就意味着有很多的这些光源
那么很多的光源怎么样去照亮一个呃
场景中的一个点呢
那我不想把他们全部都看一遍
那我把它们做一做归类对吧
然后我呵呵
怎么样才能近似出他们整体上照亮某一个点
召唤出来的结果是什么啊
这就是lcs的一个思想
这块它是可以做呃
他解决的问题啊
这叫什么呢
嗯many light问题啊
咱们刚才才提对吧
many light问题很多光源的问题它是可以解决的啊
ok那这如果大家有有兴趣的话
可以继续看这块的文章
然后呢我的一个个人理解啊
嗯如果真的想完全解决
从环境光照过来的阴影问题
那么大家很可能在未来的10年之内
大家就会产生一些实际的方法
在用real time ray tracing啊
这里r t r t指的是real time ray tracing呃
来解决这个问题的一些一些方法
然后如果让我来做的话
我觉得我差不多吧
应该能想到一些办法能够解决它
我的理解是呃
r t r t很可能是一个终极解决方案
因为real time retracing嘛
它本来用的就是pass tracing
加上doring的一个思路
那么呃他应该就可以解决这些所有的这些呃
跟sampling这些样本不足之类有关的一些问题吧
好吧嗯那行大家可以看到
所以我觉得一个非常相关的东西是什么呢
呵呵一个一个最相关的东西吧
和这节课最相关的东西就是p r t precomputed
radiance transfer
因为咱们说清楚这种方方法
t t方法是可以得到非常准确的
从环境光来的阴影的好吗
但是呢咱们那就对吧
咱们同学们上下来games这节课
大家肯定知道
我的平常一个分析问题的一个思路对吧
我们说a p r t能解决这个问题
那自然而然就要问这么一个事情了
代价是什么
对不对
咱们就看一看啊
说p r g好处在哪
坏处在什么地方对吧
那就是这个意思了
好吧嗯
ok那这里面呃这里我就先停一下
我看有同学们有什么问题吗
对吧
我有同学问啊
哈哈哈哈呃这个意思哈
然后呢我猜是这样的哈
就是说啊关于全局光照里面
全局光照里面各种各样不同的方法吧
像什么rtx g i啊
咱们要介绍的
然后全然后屏幕空间的
然后就是probe的这些方法
通常在游戏引擎里面不太可能会只用一个
正常情况下都是一些大杂烩
把所有东西都给放在一块
那个洞穴里面的全局光照用的呃
如果我没有记错呃
应该就是说
应该就是说几种不同方案的混合体啊
就是特别是一些屏幕空间上的这些trace
以及和probe的结合啊
如果我没记错的话
呃然后基本上来说背后的科学啊还是还是一样
我还是这么说啊
咱们在咱们的课里面都会有一些覆盖
然后我还是想说一句
就是就是说这些方法是什么呢
说起来其实都没那么难
但关键就是说你如何把它给写到一个引擎里面
还能让他非常的快
而且对于任何场景他都可以work
不至于出现一些巨大的问题
这才是本事
这是工程上的本事
哈哈哈哈好吧行吧啊
那我就先说这个好吧
嗯那我先继续下一块儿了哈
嗯下一块呢就是为了p2 t
咱们做一些数学知识上的储备好吧
那我们要准备哪些知识呢
大家可以看到我们还是得从频域
然后和这块儿呃什么呢
和和和和滤波这些知识上嗯呃着手
然后我们才能理解
说到底这这所谓spark harmonix在做什么
以及说我们还需要了解一些基本的啊
奇函数的知识啊
basis方式
奇函数
那么这些都是什么呢
咱们要回到games 101啊
注意啊
这里要稍微闪一下
要变白了啊
ok电子101里面我说了什么呢
我说了傅立叶变换对吧
咱们之前说过这个事情
其实这里面更
我更把它愿意说成是傅立叶级数展开啊
这么一个理解
大家可以看到任何一个函数
比如说在这里
大家可以可以看到一个什么的这种呃
一个一个的所谓box的这样一种函数啊
不不断周期性重复的
然后呢这个函数我是可以把它给用一系列的
比如直流和交流的这些函数描述起来
说白了其实就是一个常数的一个提升
加上一系列的sin和cosin的函数
然后不断的通过增加项
然后我可以得到一个呃非常呃
不断的更好的一个逼近对吧
大家可以看到这里我增加的这些像素越多
然后我得到了这么一个组合
什么组合啊
就是一个什么什么二分之a
大家看下面和什么cos的多少多少啊
这么一个函数
然后我我把这些函数所有东西都加起来
减起来像这些
然后我就可以得到越来越准的一逼近啊
然后大家可以看到这么一个结果
那么有同学说我这里说sin和cos in
这里我怎么只有cosin呢
那是因为这个函数本身是一个特殊的函数
它是一个偶函数
偶函数左右对称的啊
然后所以说像这些sin像自动就是零了
仅仅是因为它特殊啊
正常情况下
任何一个函数
咱们都可以写成一个常数和若干sin项
cos项的一些组合
那么这些三项q3 项呢
大家可以看到这里面的东西啊
大家看到什么tw 3 tw 5 tw 7 tw就意味着说啊
这些sin和cosi
它们之间它们的周期是不一样的
或者说他们的频率是不一样的对吧
哎他们频率不一样
就意味着说大家从这图上就可以看出来
我一开始用一个呃cosin函数
看起来挺smooth的对吧
后来我就引入了一个这个cos函数
看起来哎它变化就大很多了
我就可以加入一些细节对吧
然后我再引入一些变化更快的sin和cos
我就可以加入更多的细节
然后我来描述整个这个原始的函数长什么样
那么所有的函数
都可以通过类似这么一种方式来描述
那咱们为什么要这么说呢
那是因为傅里叶值基数展开
他就告诉我们
任何一个函数我都可以写成一堆sin和cos的呃
所谓线性组合对不对
并且呢这些sin函数和cos函数
它们都有一些呃各自对应的频率啊
这么个意思
然后从最低频率也就是完全不变
一个constant开始
然后到稍微有一些频率上的变化
到变化的非常剧烈诶
它是有一个这么一个隐含着的关系的
就是说他们的这些奇函数
这些函数sin和cosin之间
他们各自的频率都不一样
那么一个函数表示成其他这些函数的线性组合
呃
然后我们就管这些其他的这些函数啊
就叫叫做叫做奇函数
然后这些奇函数他们前面各自会乘上一个系数
然后所有东西都加起来
就可以得到原始的函数了哈
这么个思路
那这也是咱们今天要用的一个重要思路
那么咱们在game 701中还提到这么一件事对吧
就是关于这个频率的这么一个事情
那呃我们刚才说这高频低频对吧
高频低频也就是这个信号变化的快还是不快
所谓变化的快还是不快
我们指的不是指在呃所谓真正在时间上
这个信号一直在抖
不是这么个意思啊
我们说在空间上这个信号
如果说比如说你在空间上画一道线
然后这条线呢它经过了不同的这个
就比如这张图像上的不同位置
你把它这值给显示出来
它到底变化是是对非常剧烈的
还是一个比较平缓的一个一个变化趋势
比如大家可以看到人物的头发上这块
我们就认为它变化非常剧烈对吧
一根一根的嘛
这非常明显的嘛
那背景上变化就非常不剧烈
因为颜色就差不多嘛
就是这个意思好吧
咱们说这个意思
那么大家可以看到呢
对于任何一个函数那一张图
那自然就是二维的函数了
我可以把他的这个频频率上啊
就是频域上对应的内容被显示出来啊
这就是它的所谓频谱啊
然后在右边在右边呢
咱们在game 101中间解释过很多问题
比如说为什么会有这个十字形的这些东西
咱们在这就不说了
在这咱们就只看什么呢
就是说啊在这个频谱的最中心这块
我们是认为它是最低频的内容
然后在这个呃稍微向外一些这些区域
我们就认为它是高频的内容
那么对于任何一张自然的图片来说
绝大多数都是一些低频的内容
比如咱们看人脸上这些颜色变化就比较少
人的衣服上变化就比较少对吧
基本上是这样
那么如果说我们可以做一个滤波这样一种操作
比如说我们留下在频域上
也就是它的频谱上面啊
留下来它最低频的这一部分
然后我们把最低频的这些部分呢
变回原来的图上
然后我就会我就会发现啊
这是只用最最低频的这么些部分
我就已经可以得到一张相对模糊的一张图了
对吧
也也也正是说明了这么一个问题啊
就是说对于一个信号来说
我保留它的低频的部分
然后我其实还是能基本上看
你得明白这个图是在干什么对吧
这么个意思
那么这里面我主要想跟大家说的
就是这个标题啊
这个意思什么是filter
所谓滤波
滤波就是说我要去掉一系列的这些频呃
对应频率上的内容
比如像这里这里我们所用的一个所谓滤波器
就叫做低通滤波器
low pass filter
我留的是什么
留的是最低频率
那也就是说比它的频率高的地方
我都把它扔了
那我对应的原始的这个函数
或者咱们管它叫信号
那自然就是由低频的信号组成的
那看到的就是一些模糊的东西嘛
对吧
咱们之前都这么说过
并且呢咱们之前还提过这么一件事啊
在时域和频域他们有一个操作是相对应的
什么呢
就是说在实际上我们如果要做卷积
所谓卷积呢它其实就是一个模糊操作啊
咱们在图形学里面不怎么特别说这个卷积操作
我们就认为比如说啊拿了一幅图
任何一个点
我都取它周围的就是3x31个区域
然后把它这这这3x3里面的像素的颜色
我都算一个平均
然后我再写回这个点里面去
那大家知道我取个3x3
这个挺小的
我要取个什么9x9或者什么
那这样的话我这个图就会变得非常模糊
是不是这个意思
那这个操作啊
就是对于任何一个点
都取到周围的一片这些区域
然后并且把他们一片区域里面
结果综合综合再写回这个点
这个操作就叫就叫做卷积哈
然后在时域上做卷积
也就相当于在原始的函数上做一个卷积
然后就等于是在频率上做一个乘积
那么频域上做乘积是什么意思呢
就是说我原始的图我可以把它的频谱写出来
大家可以看到这里有一个对应了
对吧
呃图到频谱
然后呢对于他的所谓
我们认为卷积这种东西叫卷积核啊
就是说我取它周围的多大这么一块多大
这块我可以拿一个某种函数来表示
这里呢用一个box
对不对
3x3的一个box
然后把它的对应的频谱也写成出来
那这个两个呃
频谱在频域会发生一个相乘的操作
什么相乘呢
大家看到这个基本上来说啊
这个box变成频率之后
他还是个box
虽然有一点漏出来这些高频的一些东西
然后但是它有些地方是接近一的
有些地方是零的
那零乘以原来对应这个位置上的值
那就是零对吧
他就好像是使用了一个类似photoshop里面的一个
mask的一个东西
然后这么这主点相乘之后得到结果
就剩下的这些东西
还有剩下的这些东西
我如果再采用一个呃逆序列变化
就可以得到原始的这些信号对吧
咱们之前提这些东西呢
呃就是呃为了说明
就是说这频域和时域之间
是有一个相互对应关系的对吧
那咱们呃在这节课上的应用
是绝对没有那么麻烦的
这么个意思啊
然后这节课我们要说一个什么
上面我们就会认为啊一个更通用的理解
就是说呃比如说我们刚才说卷积啊
基本上就等于是滤波对吧
就等于是呃留下来
比如低频的一些什么东西
咱们可以这么理解
那么我们这节课要用的一个知识是什么呢
我会认为哈两个函数乘起来
然后再做积分
我就可以认为这是一个卷积操作
或者是一个滤波的一个操作啊
那么这是什么意思呢
也可以理解成诶这不就是时域上的两个信号
fx和gx一个卷积吗
然后它不就等于是频域上两个信号相乘的
那频率上这两个信号各自都对应一个频谱
那我现在来说这件事情
如果说这两个信号各自的频谱
只要有其中一个它是低频的
那整个呃他们在频在频率上乘出来的结果
那就是低频的
那回来之后得到的这么一个
就是所谓呃成先成绩再积分
得到结果也势必是低频的
没问题吧
也就是说任何的一种操作
只要他满足这么一个性质
我们管它叫product integral啊
就是一个函数f x乘以一个gx
然后我再把它给积分起来这么一个东西
我就认为它存在一定的滤波意义了
就是这么一个意思
然后呢嗯我我们之前所说
我们对于任何一种函数或者信号
我们都可以说呃什么是低频
什么是低频呢
我们是一个简单的一个理解
那就是说只要他看起来smooth啊
咱们之前不是在做那个叫什么
split sum的时候
咱们说过这个事情吗
就是说它的呃
我说一个函数smooth
指的是说它的变化会没有那么距离啊
这么个意思
然后呃这这种就叫做低频
然后呢一个嗯我们要用到的一个结论是什么呢
就是说啊我我最后积分出来的结果
就是咱们刚才看啊两个函数相乘
然后呃然后再把它给卷积呃
不是再把它给积分起来
得到的结果他肯定是嗯嗯是这这这叫什么呢
就是这呃就得到结果的频率哈
就一定是啊有这两个函数
fx和gx各自的频率的最低的一个频率
来决定的这么一个思路哈
啊ok啊行吧
来我们来看看有没有同学有什么问题哈
就是说这块儿我们做一做知识储备
这是对的哈
嗯有同学说这里得到的是一个数值
而不是一个函数
为什么是卷积呢
啊这是这没问题啊
然后我觉得这个同学问的非常非常对哈
然后就是说这里面自然而然大家看到这个函数
这个积分最后给你得到一个结果是一个值啊
那如果说你的这个而fx的任意一个x
它在不同的位置上啊
然后这个gx或者这样说吧
我其实应该把它写成g y啊
这样就清楚一点了
好吧哈哈哈哈
ok呃总之这个事情不是特别重要
我觉得就是说这里面呢基本上来说
大家就只嗯差不多知道这么一个事情就好了
为什么是最低的
是因为大家可以考虑在频域上这两个函数
它们各自的频谱它们会发生相乘
然后只要有其中一个是低频的
那么乘出来的结果就是低频的嘛
就是说只留下了中间的最呃中间的那一部分吧
咱们刚才的这个意思哈
ok那这块来说就是简单的怎么说呢
就是概念上咱们理解一下这个思路
这是用在后面的
呃呃呃我们嗯再试图说
比如说rendering equation
这块到底怎么理解这么一个事情
好吧嗯
ok那这里就是说我认为哈
咱们接受这么一个观点的情况下
后续就会比较好进行
那么我们这里就要给大家介绍一个
这个基本概念了啊
叫什么呢
叫基函数啊
basis functions啊
那奇函数是什么
基数展开的时候
你刚才已经说了
对不对
那也就是说基函数是呃
你如果用呃用啊
不是是把一个函数可以描述成很多
其他函数的线性组合
大家可以看到这里
你用一个函数f x
然后呢你你你有一系列函数bi啊
bi他们各自都是个函数啊
然后呢这些函数我前面都可以乘上某个系数
然后我们把它全部加起来
我就可以得到呃原始的这么一个函数
那我就说这一系列的函数bi诶
它就是呃它就是奇函数
ok就这么个就这么个意思呃
自然而然奇函数大家可以看到就是目的
就是说我可以用这种奇函数的不同组合
就可以描述不同的呃这些函数了
对不对
那么我们刚才说的傅里叶的这些级数呃
一堆三呀
cos呀
还有那个常数
他们就形成了一套奇函数
这是没问题的对吧
因为它可以描述刚才咱们说的那么一个box方式
嘛对吧
然后同样道理啊
还有一个嗯比较常用的奇函数
大家肯定之前在学微积分的时候就已经学过了
这是什么函数呢
这个函数就是呃就是多项式的嗯这么个系列
那什么系列呢
就是一
然后x然后x平方x x方
一直到x比较高的这个高次的这么一个呃
一系列函数放在一块儿
哎大家会发现这是什么对吧
我说一个函数
我可以描述成这些函数的线性组合
这个东西就和泰勒展开是非常像的
是不是对吧
嗯比如说给你一个函数
然后你要把它展开成这个这一加x加x平方
加什么东西
就是就是说有这么一个呃意思在里面哈
所以奇函数不是一个非常复杂的话题啊
它就是一系列函数
然后它们的组合可以描述某个函数而已啊
这个意思啊
那行
这里面呢呃差不多我们要做的知识储备就在这
那用这些知识
基本上咱们就可以进行后续的所谓啊
对于environment lighting的频域分析
以及sparkle harmonix
那到此为止
我先问一问同学有什么其他的问题好吗
ok是哈
刚才我又想刚才这位同学问的问题是非常对的
不是fx乘gx再做积分
这个例子并不好
那咱们应该把它说成是啊fx乘以某个g
然后x y或者就是y然后再对x积分啊
呃这样差不多
ok嗯好呃
没有什么其他问题的话呢
咱们在这就继续进行了好吧
这些这些知识和basic function啊
那么下面我们说什么呢
我们要说啊
还记得我们要解决的问题吗对吧
在环境光照下怎么样把这阴影给搞出来对吧
那么呃咱们可以这样想啊
就是说我们先一步一步来
我们先看
如果说我先解决咱们之前相同的问题
我们先不考虑阴影啊
如果环境光照呃下
然后我要先解决一个简单问题
那就是呃给你整个环境光
给你一个物体
这个物体全部都是def呃
那如果在这种情况下
我有没有什么好的办法去解决它
就这个意思先把shading给做出来
咱们先先不考虑shadow啊
这个意思
那言论这个问题我们先引入呃
我们现在需要用的这个数学工具
就叫做spherical harmonix
而这个概念哈
就是说呃工业界的朋友们肯定都是接触过的
而这个阶这个概念在一开始学的时候
是挺麻烦的一件事啊
因为它本身又涉及到频率的设计
然后本身呢又涉及到一些呃
就是它本身各那各种各样的运算性质
本身又带积分啊
就挺麻烦的
但事实上来说我们的一个理解啊
或者说我个人一个理解方式什么的
咱们没必要把他想的特别特别困难啊
spherical harmonix是什么
首先咱们先定义它是一系列的二维的奇函数啊
他们就是一系列的奇函数
也就是说它不是一个函数
它是一系列的函数好吗
这这个系列中的每个函数它都是二维的
并且呢都是定义在球面上的
什么叫定义在球面上的
你可以理解成是对这个呃对方向的一个函数
大家知道在三维空间中任何一个方向对吧
它其实就是二维的函数嘛
呃二二就是一个二维的东西啊
就是就是这么个意思
二维的变量吧
这样说
然后为什么说三维空间中
一个一个方向是二维的呢
是因为这个方向你可以拿c它和发音来描述嘛
对不对
两个数可以描述的东西
那自然就是二维的咯
对吧啊
没问题啊
然后就是说它它整个定义的是一个在球面上
对吧
球面上不同的点
你就可以认为球面上某一个点
就描述了一个独特的方向嘛
或者认为单位球面上的一个点就是一个方向嘛
好吧
那就是说整个spark harmonix
是定义在这么一个球面上的
那么球面上可能有不同的值嘛对吧
那这二维的这个函数呃
他就是呃通过这种方式
然后定义在球面上
然后球面上任何一个方向的值是多少
那每一个storical harmonix呃
它都是一个独特的一个函数
定义在二维的平面上的好吧
那这么来说
那么spherical harmonics它是一系列函数
每个函数都是定义在球面上的
一个二维的一个函数
那么他的另外一个理解方式是
它其实啊就非常像在一维情况下的傅里叶级数
是这么个意思
那么咱们知道傅里叶级数他们做了什么事对吧
给你任何一个函数
你可以把它拆成呃这这种不同频率的
这这呃这么一些部分对吧
1111些常数和sin和和和和cos
然后sin和cos各自的频率都不一样对吧
那同样道理对于spacle hamx
咱们大家来看这幅图
它其实啊和傅里叶的这些这个系列
这么些sin和cos它是非常非常相似的一个概念
什么呢
就是说它本身也存在说不同的这种呃
频率的这么一个函数
然后不同频率的函数呢
它嗯个数也不同啊
这么一个思路
那咱们看这个这个图
这个图呢其实就是对这个spherical
harmonics的一个可视化啊
这个可视化是这么一个意思
就是说嗯大家可以看到呃
这是分层的
对不对
那第一层也就是最上面一行
最上面一行有一个函数
这个函数呢它是一个uniform的
在球上任何一个方向它的值都是一样的
大家看到是这么一个球啊
这个意思
然后呢
大家看到这底下这第二行也就是l等于一
这里啊大家看看这里有三个函数
这里三个函数呢
他们其实就相当于是比如说某个半球上
它有一个呃是是有不同的值的啊
另外半球上对称的有不同的值
然后嗯他们这些函数各自的朝向不一样
不管怎么样
这是三个定义在球面上的函数
这个也没问题对吗
然后大家可以看第三行有五个这种函数
这五个函数它们的频率又都是一样的
但只不过呢各自长得又有点区别
然后第四行也是一样的
就是l等于三
这一行大家可以看到这些函数
它们各自描述的频率都是一样的
然后呢然后他们的个数又多了些呵呵
然后他们长得也各自不太相同
有可能是旋转不太相同
有可能就是就是说呃形状就就不一样了对嘛
但是它们的频率也都是一样的
这么个意思哈
所以说这里呢spherical harmonix
没有任何特殊的地方
它们仅仅是二维的函数
并且这些二维的函数它们有不同的频率
而每一种频率上有几种不同
有几种不同类型的二维函数而已啊
这么个意思
那咱们现在呢看得稍微深入一点啊
这个意思就是说大家能不能告诉我
比如说啊嗯在这第几行
咱不说第几行了
就说这l等于几吧好吧
然后这这嗯l等于几的情况下
它有几个不同的函数呢
比如说大家看l等于零的时候
它有一个函数对吧
l等于二的时候
他有五个函数
然后l等于三的时候
它有七个函数
有没有同学能够直接告诉我说这个啊
呃就是l等于几的时候呢
它这个函数的数量是几
呃这是一个非常简单的公式啊
有同学已经告诉了我们答案对吧
2l加一对吧
大家可以看到就是这么回事嘛对吧
这l等于零的时候
大家可以看到直接2l加1=1嘛
l等于一的时候呢
它就是就是啊
就是呃呃这叫这叫什么2x1+1嘛
就是三个
而是2l加一啊
不是二的多少次方向盘
不是啊
而是这么个意思
那么这是这是要说的这个事情
那么这里呢人们根据他们每一个每一行吧
表示的不同频率呃
人们就给这s h i s phical harmonix
起了不同的名字
就是说比如说l等于零
我们管它叫第零阶的s h
然后呢l等于一的时候
我们管它叫第一阶的s h
那么每一接的s h
有几个不同的s h的奇函数呢
那就是2l加一个
并且不只是2l加一个啊
而且他们还有个固定的编号
他们的编号就从负l到l
大家看这底下我这边呃
写了一个这个m和m表示的就是他们的编号
大家可以看到
比如说l等于零
也就是第零阶的s h它只有一个编号零啊
然后l等于一的话
它的编号就有-101
然后l等于二
那就是-2-1012
然后发现诶他就不是从从-二到呃到二嘛
那那这里不就是从-3~3吗对吧
然后就这就更加说明了每一行呃
或者没接的s h啊
它有多少个这样的函数
就是这么个思路吧好吧哎这是这是一个少
另外一个事情是这样的
有没有同学告诉我
比如说我我要是说前n阶啊
前n阶
比如说我说前三阶意思就是l等于零
l等于一
l等于二啊
这个意思前n阶总共有多少个g函数
这个非常有趣的一件事情
哈哈哈哈哈呃好吧
那肯定有同学立刻可以告诉我
这个这个答案呢对吧
那就是就是n平方个嘛
对不对
比如说前一阶
前一阶是什么
就是第零阶嘛对吧
那是什么呢
就是一个那前两节那总共多少
12344个前三阶多少
123456789
前三阶九个
前四阶多少
16个就是n平方
就那么简单啊
前n阶就意味着呃这l等于零一
一直到n减一啊
咱们把这个呃给给说清楚对吧
那这就是人们对这些s h的一些观察嘛
简单来说就是这个事啊
呃所以咱们再回到刚才说
这s s h它到底是什么
它就是一堆函数啊
没接它有它拥有一种频率阶越高
它描述的频率越高
呃
然后呃对应的这个呃基函数的数量也多一些啊
就这么介绍
没别的好吧
那嗯现在咱们呢问一个不相关的问题啊
哎有同学问说诶既然付林业这这这些东西呃
大家知道傅里叶可以做2d的傅里叶变换
对不对
诶那如果说我可以做2d的傅里叶变换
我为什么给你一个比如球面的函数
我不把它展开成theta和f
展开成theta和f
不就是哎我们之前所说的地球已展
展开成为地图嘛
展开成地图不就二维的图吗
二维的图我为什么不做一个二维的傅里叶变换
我不照样可以分析这些对应的呃这些属性吗
嗯对不对
有没有同学会问这么一个问题
那我为什么要用spark harmonics来描述它呢
那这里啊我简单直接给大家一个结论哈
那是因为咱们平常在rendering里面用到很多
这些球面上的这些函数哈
如果说你要把它给展开成二维的傅里叶呃
这些这些基数
然后你再根据不同的频率去考虑它
你最后再做一些近似
然后你得到的最后的结果
你再把它变回整个球面上去
你会发现很可能啊这个球面上被你弄出来
要疯了啊
很可能球面上被你弄说要缝的
这是这是很正常的一件事情
好吧
然后哈哈哈哈哈
然后然后就这样一来呢
就是说你看sper和monic
它本来就是定义在球面上任何一个不同方向的
然后从这些可视化大家来看啊
他在球面上非常非常连续的
对不对
也就是说他很适用于直接用它来分析
球面上的一些函数的性质啊
这么一个思路好吧
那这样一来关于spherical harmonics
我们做了一系列的这些呃观察分析哈
然后就首先我是希望通过这个观察分析
打消大家对他的这些所谓恐惧感
它它没有任何特殊的地方
真的它就是二维的函数吧对吧
这些二维的函数被归类成了各种不同的频率的
段呃而已
然后每种频率它有一些有一些这个呃
不同的这些奇函数的数量呗
对吧
它毕竟还是奇函数啊
这么个意思
那么它的每一个奇函数肯定有同学会关心啊
这个每一个奇函数
我拿什么样的这些函数能描述出这种形状来
大家看到这l等于三对吧
呃这l等于三的
这这接的情况下
看起来这个函数长得好奇怪
而且很很有意思的
对不对
然后这些函数我拿什么写的呀对吧
然后这里我可以给大家一个答案哈
就是说每一个奇函数
它是利用一个所谓勒让德多项式来写的
勒让德多项式是非常麻烦的一个多项式
但是它毕竟是个多项式啊
就是说就是说它本身就是是写起来
数学上是挺麻烦的
这也是我为什么不愿意把这个公式给写上了
没有任何必要啊
就是说你知道一个奇函数
它长这样
它可以用某些数学工具来定义它
不同的方向上值是多少不就可以了嘛
对不对啊
ok然后这里呢
既然我们引入了spherical harmonics的一个概念
然后我们现在就想把它作为一个奇函数对吧
把它作为奇函数
大家知道奇函数是干什么的呀
不是用于说给你一个函数
你用这个基函数的线性组合
然后就可以表述原来的那个函数吗
对不对
那么我自然而然会问这么一个问题哈
那我给你一个二维的球面的函数
我问如果这个函数我要把它给展开成
用spherical harmonics
他们的线性组合来描述的这样一个函数
那么对应对应于任何一个spherical harmonics
它前面那个系数应该是谁啊
大家还记得我们刚才写了吧
任何一个f对吧
它不是等于c i乘以b i对吧
b i就是那个函数
它前面得有一个c i对吧
然后再整个求和求起来
我就问这c i是什么对吧
那这里呢这里就有一个很不错的一个性质
什么呢
就是说我要想得到说给你任何一个函数
二维的一个函数f
大家看到它的变量是我们应该往不同方向嘛
对不对
然后给你一个二维的一个函数
就是定义在球面上的一个函数
我可以立刻知道
如果他用spherical harmonix
来表示它的任意一个奇函数bi啊
他任意一个奇函数
这里面就是说大家看到这里的16个
这个这个奇函数嘛啊
它的任何一个前面对应的这个系数
c i都是谁啊
这是非常非常呃这干净利落的一个什么呢
就是我刚才说的哈哈product integral好吧
就是说两个函数先乘起来再做积分啊
就是对应位置逐点相乘
然后再做积分啊
就是说就这么简单
然后他的这个数学公式就就就在这里
然后它这是它非常不错的一个性质哈
就是说啊而且这个过程啊我们说清楚
给你任何一个函数
用任何一个basis呃
就是说用整个basis方式来描述它的时候
任何一个basis前面它的系数是多少啊
求这个系数的过程就叫做投影
这是数学上的一个定义啊
投影我任何的一个函数f omega
我都可以求出它在任何一个basis function上的投影
好吧
那同样道理
我既然知道了任何一个这些呃奇函数
它前面的这样一个系数呃是多少
那我就可以恢复原来的这个函数
只不过呢这个时候就是人们聪明的地方
哎大家知道说啊
这个veral harmonix照这种定义方法
那它l可以等于无限的
对不对
它它它它l等于一个100
它对应那一行大家就就知道得有这201个
这是嗯对吧
这个这个这个函数它可以是无限多的
那那我给你一个函数
然后我可以求出来他对任何一个呃
basis function前面的这么一个系数应该是多少
投影出来的系数是多少
那我要想恢复出来原来的函数
那我其实并不想用那么多的这些呃
记函数来描述它们
比如说我有一个函数
我就想用它前呃
这四阶前四阶的s h呃
然后我来恢复之前的那个函数对吧
诶
那我就就是说只用只需要用这么16个奇函数
它前面对应这个系数
然后我们对应乘起来就是c i乘以b i
我总共乘个16个
这么些把它加起来
我就可以恢复出原来的函数了
对不对
并且呢大家已经可以诶
已经可以看到一个不错的一个一个事情哈
那如果说我用前四阶的s h
然后我就恢复出原来的一个函数
那我就恢复出来的这个函数
是不是就只保留了最高的频率
就是这l等于三所能表述出来的频率
更高的频率
我就把它扔了
是不是这个意思
就好像说我的呃
呃在刚才说傅里叶级数的时候对吗
哎我复里叶级数的情况下
我这边嗯呃这个我如果取比如说前面五项
前面七项或者多少
大家可以看到恢复出来的这个函数啊
它的呃能表示出来的细节越来越多
那也就意味着我前面用的这些呃个数
用basis个数啊
从从低到高用的越多诶
我越能引入稍微更多一点的高频的信息
是不是这么个意思对吧好吧
那这里呢我就先放在这儿
呃
为什么呢
因为这里面给大家介绍了这
spaccommodate这个概念
后续的呢我们要说它的应用
然后这里肯定有同学会有很多的问题对吧
然后欢迎大家现在来提问
我来看一下啊啊好啊
有同学说球面展开成二维平面
对呀呃呃又有同学直接回答了
回答非常好啊
非常好对吧
哎several map
我们之前说一个环境
光环境就是environment map嘛
我可以拿veral map来描述嘛对吧
然后这张图不就是一个典型的例子
一个球面展开成了一个二维的一个一张图嘛
所以肯定是行的嘛对吧
然后就是这个意思啊
我非常不建议学spherical harmonics的时候
然后说他具体怎么写出来
那一点关系也没有好吧
这这这这这个意思
然后就是我们要理解的就是他到底在干什么呢
就是就是呃任何一个函数
我都可以把它描述成奇函数的组合
并且veral harmonics
类比于傅里叶的这些级数的奇函数
它也有个好处
就是说它从低到高
是可以把不同的频率给描述出来的
从最低频到最高频
这么个意思啊
嗯有同学问这这中间的颜色表示什么哈
啊那这里我说一下
这颜色不是频率啊
颜色不是频率
颜色表示的是它的值啊
它的值比如说它越越蓝的地方吧
它就是就越偏白的蓝色那个地方值越大
然后相应的这个黄色呢越偏白的地方
就表示它的值
它的绝对值越大
就是说他有正有负的啊
这么个意思o
那也就是说这里仅仅是它的一个可视化
咱们就以l等于一为例
l等于一的中间那个吧啊
这里看也就是说它的l等于一
m等于零
咱们说清楚
就这个函数
然后我鼠标还停在这
那就是说它在北极的地方值是非常大
南极的地方值的绝对值非常大
然后它在这整个赤道上的值都是零啊
这回就说清楚了好吧
那这指指表示它的值
那频率就是值的变化
那值的变化大还是不大
咱们一眼就可以看出来
这下面这这长得跟花儿一样
对不对
他这个变化这么剧烈
它当然就意味着哎整个l等于三
他们的频率就比整个l等于l的频率要高了
是不是
这个意思好吧啊
f是谁啊
f是谁
那应该就是我们刚才所说的这个例子了对吧
f是任意的一个函数呀
不是说我们的这个basis function
它可以表示任何的球面函数
那咱们举个例子
就是咱们要用的一个一个应用是什么呢
那就是环境光照呗
环境光是不是来自四面八方的都有值
它是不是就是一个球面的一个函数
他是不是就是我们可以理解成是f
我可以把它投影到任意的s h basis上对吧
我可以投影到很多街
然后我不管投影多少节
我只要用钱多少阶的这些呃
spark harmonix去恢复它
我就可以恢复出最低频的这些信息
ok好吧
环境呃
哦哦哦哦是这样哈
有同学问这个是每个图是一个奇函数吗
对这问的太对了哈
就是说整个一个呃嗯不不不是这么涂吧
这么一个意思就是说整个一个环境光in market map
它描述的是一个二维的一个函数
这个函数它投影到每一个奇函数上得到一个值
它不是每一个像素这么投啊
不是这么个意思啊
ok啊
ok行吧
这怎么选重要的一组
我这没太明白什么叫重要呢
就是说咱们会认为最低频算是最重要嘛
那就是从最低频到最高频开始取呗
也就是说我们要恢复一个函数的话
我只需要用它的嗯这些嗯对应最低几阶
也就是前多少阶
咱们刚才问这个问题吗
前n阶的这个呃集函数据恢复它就对了嘛
好吧哈哈哈哈好吧哦
有同学问这个积分怎么算是吧
这积分怎么算呢
就肯定是说你要对不同的方向进行采样了对吧
然后然后这块算这些东西
那肯定是嗯
不是那么容易能够算出一个解析解的
对吧啊
那自然而然我这么问
应该就可以得到一个结论了对吧
就是说我这很可能这个计算啊
我在实际上嗯渲染的时候我是承担不起的
有可能要拿在渲染之前
这就是我们要说的预计算的一个思想啊
马上来说好吗
嗯每一组频率里面加入怎么选
通常人们不学
通常人们就是说我我用到前多少阶
那就是前多少阶的这个呃内部的这些我都用啊
这个意思很少有人在这个比如说l等于二
中间我挑两个
让我来描述
他不会这样的话
通常不会啊
这个意思好吧啊对这是有同学回答了对吧
钱多少阶的计函数我都用
就这个意思
我选的就是说我取前多少
借这么一个信息而已啊
通常人们这么个用法
那么这里呢我跟大家说一个
稍微更深一点话题哈
就是说这里呃人们说得到这么一个系数
这么一个过程哈
呃这个过程叫投影
对不对
哎那这个过程其实啊大家可以想象空间中
如果我想描述一个点或者描述一个向量吧对吧
然后这个向量我是不是可以用一个括号里面
比如说x值y的值
z的值来来描述它对吧
然后这个怎么来的呢
咱们在game 101里面就说过对吧
比如说我在空间中有一个呃
由一组相互垂直的x轴
y轴
z轴对吧
然后这种情况下给你任何一个向量
它对应的坐标是什么呢
我就要对这个向量呃
它投影到x投影到y
投影到z上面的这这这个值呃
然后我就我就可以得到它就相当于是什么呢
任何一个向量都是哎
比如说c x乘以x轴加c y乘以y轴
加c z乘以z轴
所以说啊数学这些东西都是相通的
对不对
在这种向量这种表述下
哎那是向量x轴y轴轴z轴
这就是三个奇函数呗对吧
然后呢我要想得到任意一个向量
用这些奇函数x和y和z
它的这个组合怎么样得到
那我就想得到它的这个前面的系数呗
想得到前面系数怎么样呢
就做投影的是不是一个完全一个道理对
所以说这里是一个非常有意思的一个事儿
就是说这些东西都是相通的嘛对吧
然后另外一个事情哈
诶大家会发现这么一个问题
诶我给你个向量
我要想把它投影到x轴或者投影到y轴
诶我要做的一个事情是一个点成对吗
诶对吧
我要做的是一个点乘
而这里面我为什么我做投影
其实要做一个积分呢对吧
要做一个product integral呢
诶我们马上就会说其实product integral啊
它的本质就是一个典称啊这么一个思路
所以说唉这些事情都是都是可以触类旁通的啊
这么少嗯
另外还有一件事情
还是从刚才的类比可以看出的什么呢
哎刚才我们说在一个空间里面
人们平常会喜欢用这x轴
y轴和z轴通常都是要相互垂直的
是不是这个意思
或者投影到z轴值都是零啊对吧
哎这种东西是是不是代表了某种一个
什么样的性质
哎我其他的基函数
如果说我把一个奇函数投影到一个奇函数上
像这个s h啊
哎比如说我把这个l等于一
m等于-1这么一个函数投影到l等于三
m等于二
投影到这个奇函数上去
我得到的结果会不会还是零呢
哈哈如果来投影是零
它是唉我们能不能说这两个奇函数互相垂直的
就这么一个意思哈
我们马上就说啊
这是叫做正交的一个属性啊
这么个意思
所以说大家会发现这些既而入什么的定义
基本上是完完全一样的
不管是在线性代数上
还是说咱们在这个spherical harmonics上面
这当然个人一点点理解啊
这么个意思行吧啊
那咱们下面就来说啊
我们引入了这么一个呃奇函数呃
引入这个奇函数的时候呢
我们就呃先用它来解决一个
超级简单的一个问题
什么问题啊
咱们说这里我们要解决在环境光照下
然后我去做呃diffuse物体
它的shading问题啊
仍然还没考虑到shadow呢啊这个意思
那么大家看到我这后面这些药就用的是呃呵呵
呃rui教授的嗯
就是以前做的课件了哈
就是说嗯这里用他的这个课件啊
我我觉得我这是完完全全
不敢在上面改任何东西
因为什么
因为因为是这样哈
就是说我们上节课还是上上节课呀
我跟大家说了对吧
这这spiral和monix就是我当年博士的老板
ravi ramsay教授
他引入到图形学的
正是因为他做了这部分工作
才有了之后的整个一个p r t的10年
可以这么来说
引领了一个时代啊
这么个意思好
那么这里呢哎有同学问
我们之前不是已经说过这shading怎么做了吗
对没错
我们只是说在这里举一个例子
然后我们来引入说后面的这个呃
就是对于更一般的一些情况
这p r d要怎么做啊
这么个意思
那行那咱们就来看呃
之前嗯就是说呃
我们怎么样去解决这么一个问题哈
那这里呢我们上一节课在说split sum的时候
说到这么一件事
就是说呢我如果说有一个环境光
我去直接去
比如说沿着镜面反射方向
然后我去查它的某一个值哦
那我就会感觉到我会看到一个镜子嘛
对不对
就是这么个意思
那么如果说我要先把我的一个环境光
给做一个filtering
filtering是什么呀
不就是convolution
不就是模糊嘛对吧
然后呢我先把整个的这个呃环境光呃
球面函数对吧
我给做一个模糊
做完了一个模糊之后
我同样也是去哎沿着它的镜面反射方向
我去在这个模糊了的environment light上
我去查一个方向
诶
我去查这个方向
得到了这么一个结果
看起来好像就是diffuse
对不对
哎大家从右边这幅图看起来就好像是这样
所以说呢一个profter过来的环境光
加上一次查询
就好像说我不做嗯
嗯也filter
不做任何的滤波
然后呢我却在任何一个点
我在往任何不同的方向
我过去查这个整个emament
来听它的值是多少对吧
然后这两个我们上节课说
这两个可以认为基本上是一个等价的
这么一个过程
这就是我们之前说的prefer
对不对
然后呢之前ruby做了一个什么工作
这还是他在博士期间做的一个工作哈
大家可以看到啊
如果说啊我们认为runing equation里面
我们现在要解决的呃
这个问题在diffuse b r d f下啊
得到了一个简化
那咱们就可以有一个非常好的性质
那么首先呢我们来说一下diffuse b2 d f
为什么简单呢
是因为它是非常smooth的
对不对对吧
然后呢在rendering equation里面呃
我们要解决的是什么呢
我们解决的不是lighting乘以b r d f
然后我们这里又说这里考虑shading
然后就没有visibility对吧
还有一个cos in term
这里暂时咱们先不管它
咱们不是说b r d f和b2 d f乘以cos
咱们都认为b d f项对吧
那所以说我其实要解决的什么来着诶
lighting是整个environment map过来的
一个球面的一个函数
然后整个b2 d f是定义在整个半球上的
一个很光滑的一个函数
然后他们两个做主点的相乘
并且我要把它给积分起来
这不就是我说的两个函数
你要做一个所谓product integral的一个操作嘛
对吧
然后大家会发现这么一个事情啊
然后这哪两个函数来着
就是说环境光环境光可以非常的复杂
对不对
它可以有低频
可以有高频
然后呢b2 d f这个东西如果它是diffuse的话
它就有一个非常好的性质了
大家看这里它就好像是一个低通滤波器一样
就是这么一个思路啊
然后呢啊ruby就发现了这么一件事情
既然啊这个diffuse b r d f这么简单
就算带上高三项的
然后呢我我是不是就可以用呃
很很少的一些spherical harmonics的这些基函数
去描述它
大家知道ical harmonix
咱们刚才才说对吧
它是从最低频开始描述
一直描述稍微高频一点
再高频一点对吧
大家可以看到
如果说就我要用spark hamx来描述
diffub r d f项目
那么我其实啊我差不多只需要三阶呃
spherical harmonix我就可以把它给恢复的很好了
大家可以看到这个这右边这张图
右边这张图怎么理解啊
这个l是横轴
从左往右对
也可以看看这些早期这些图做的好难看啊
但是不管怎么样
他是非常能说明问题的哈
给你一个diffuse b r d f
你要把它投影到spark harmonics上面去
那么你会发现第零阶段
第一阶段
第二阶段他们的差不多
比如说平均的这些
你得出来这些系数ci各自都是多少
你会发现当它这个这个函数啊
投影到第三阶去的时候
就发现诶这第三阶基本上来说就没什么内容了
第四阶好像呃已有点什么负的
但是也很少了吧
也就是说我们可以认为从这第三阶开始
也就是说鼠标这个位置
然后这么一个b r d f项目
我去我去投影到spark和monix的时候
我后面这些接触我投影不投影无所谓了嘛
对不对
也就是说我投影到前三阶基本上还有值
投影到后面就没有值了
这个事情是非常有道理的
说明什么呢
就说明了是啊
就是说啊说明的是这么一个事情哈
就是说可以认为我如果说要把defb 2 d f
然后我我要把它投影到spark harmonics
只有前面几节有值
意味着他根本就没有
后面几节所描述的高频信息
就这么个意思了
大家想想是不是这么一个道理
如果有任何一个函数
比如说我用一个cos
什么什么加sin
什么东西来描述到前几届就ok了
然后后面我根本没必要描述
就意味着这个函数本身他就挺低频的
是不是这意思
然后这个图就说明了什么问题
说明b r d f就是挺低频的吧
哎那这个时候咱们在用的
我们刚才在给大家做知识储备的时候
做了这么一个思路哈
唉两个函数做product integral的时候对吧
两个函数做product integral的时候
我最后乘出来的这么一个结果的频率
肯定是由最低的频率的那个函数来决定的对吧
这也就换句话说我这环境光我不管它有多高频
只要我用它来照亮一个diffuse物体
我是不是基本看不到什么高频信息
而这个事情是不是大家想一想就可以
显而易见的对吧
大家从来没有见过一个diffuse的球
上面会反射出来非常非常复杂的光照的
是不是这意思对吧
也就是说哎我们就可以利用这个信息了对吧
我们利用这些信息干什么呢
我们不是要做任意频率的environment lighting
它照亮了一个diffuse物体
并且不考虑visibility的情况下呃
它的shading的值是多少吗
那这里其实就告诉我说
既然b r d f本身
我都可以用非常低频的前三阶s h来描述它
那么我为什么lighting也要描述那么高的频率呢
对不对
于是呢
ruby就做了一个这么一个实验
大家可以看到啊
左边是一个呃
就是这么一个一个一个可以认为是正确的结果
吧
好吧
正确的协定结果
那么右边是这样的
如果说我用呃
就是前一阶the spherical harmonics来描述光照
大家知道这前一节也就是一个函数对吧
这个函数就是一个完全constant的
然后他如果用一阶的这么一个光照来描述呃
这个光照的话
他去照亮这个球
它会得到一个看起来非常平的一个结果
然后这当然就不太好
那么如果它引入前两阶的呃s h来描述光照
我们说清楚啊
这里面是这样的
就是说我光照到底要用多少阶的s h来描述
是这么个意思
刚才那个是实验
说明b2 d f它的频率不会超过三阶的s h
能表示的频率这么个意思
这里金色的是光照
那么光照来说
如果我去签两阶的s h
那我得到了这个结果
看起来好像已经不错了
对不对
那么如果说我取前三阶的s h
来描述整个的光照的话
那我可以看到两个结果几乎就完全一致的
而且大家可以看到一些数值的这些呃
他们的误差可以计算出来
而是小于是等于1%的
然后正常情况下
他们还得出了一个更通用的结论
对于任何的光照条件
只要你的材质是diffused
我都可以用前三阶的s h来描述光照
然后用它来照亮这么一个呃
呃这个diffuse这么这么个物体啊
这么个意思啊
然后呃这刚才原理咱们就已经说了对吧
就是说原理是
因为b r d f响本来已经是低频了
你现在在做的事情
就是光照像和b2 d f项目的所谓product integral
那么你的光照像势必也不需要超过三阶的s
智能表示的一个频率
就是这么一个思路好吧
那行了
那这样就差不多说明白了
s h的一个最直接的一个应用
那肯定有同学问我说
我说我具体
我我我就是用s h描述了这么一个呃这个光照
然后我怎么样做这个协定呢
是吧
哎这里就是另外的事情了
我就不再多说了
这里只是给大家举一个例子
就是当时引入spa monux的这么一个意义哈
然后呃我来看看啊
有同学问问题哈
s h近似的是什么
诶我刚才说了对吧
s h这里说清楚了
是通过先分析b2 d f的频率
然后来决定说我要用多少g的s h来近似光照
仅仅是光照哈
然后f呢那自然指的就是任意的嗯
环境光的这个贴图了对吧
然后当然是个球面函数了
对不对
嗯好嗯好吧
有一些我没太明白的哈
嗯ok ok嗯是哈啊
没有同学问s h是不是
就是说只能应用在diffuse上了
那这是不一定的啊
虽然这里面其实我觉得同学看到了一些本质
j s h呢其实是非常适合来描述一些低频的
所有光照的对吧
是这么个意思
只不过这里说的意思是说
在如果说物体也是diffuse的情况下
你根本用不着
那么高频的光照就是想说这么一个意思
那么这样我把这块说完
这块嗯
就是说ruby在提出了这么呃呃
就就这一套这个spa monux的理论之后
然后呢他把他写进了自己的毕业论文
然后并且呢呃他说这么一个事儿
如果spargo harmony我就只用前三阶
那么他最后呃是可以写成一个所谓
polynomial的一个呃
就是就是平方的啊
和这个shading的
shading point的法线相关的一个函数
所以这就是为什么我最后得到的光照
其实可以写成一个二次型啊
这么个意思
这块大家看这是fyi
我就简单跟大家说一下
目的是为了说什么
目的是为了告诉大家rain呢当时写了一个代码
这个代码是这样的
是这样一个函数
然后这个函数是用来计算在环境光照下
任何一个点
它的呃shading的结果是什么的
然后算这个时间定的结果需要多少行代码
大家可以看到两行
这就是历史上著名的两行代码
拿到博士学位的一个呵呵一个例子
ok这是真的哈
ruby当时的呃
就是就是相当于是这两行代码的背后
这些数学呢当然非常多了对吧
就是说不管怎么样
就这两行代码
然后他就这个获得了博士学位
并且引领了整个一个时代
并且开创了整个运用sparmonix
去解决很多实际问题的一个时代
也就是也也相当于算是开始了这么一个
plt的一个时代啊
这么个意思
不过这里我还是说清楚啊
这里面仍然是考虑shading不是shadow啊
这里面也仅仅是说这个事情
就是说大家用spacle harmonics这么一个事情
好吧好
那就这么一个意思啊
嗯ok那这里简单总结一下啊
就是说我们呃刚才就是一个例子
在用奇函数对吧
那奇函数可以干什么呢
可以表示任何的函数对吧
只要说我用足够多的积函数的个数
或者说s h的话
那就是足够多的前n阶对吧
然后呢呃如果说我想表述说呃
一个函数我只想留他的呃低频的信息
那很简单咯
那我只需要取前面的一些接触的呃
低阶的一些呃这些奇函数呃
他们前面对应的系数
我来重建这个原函数
得出来的必然就是低频的信号对吧
哎然后呢我们刚才还提到这么一件事儿对吧
然后就是说如果有两个函数都是拿呃
这种奇函数s h的这个基函数来表述的
那么他们的product integral啊其实是一个简称啊
这个刚才我我没下这个结论之后
我再告诉大家是怎么回事好吧
那么呃我们实际上要解决的是什么
什么事情对吧
刚才说的那个例子解决还是shading
而且还是diffuse物体对吧
然后也没有阴影对吧
那么下面来说我们现在就要解决这个问题
第一我不希望它是没有阴影的
我要引入阴影
第二我能不能还是用同样的计函数的什么思路
但是我还能解决啊
这种呃是嗯就就就是说任意的b2 d f的问题
比如说像是gloy b r d f我也不用限制
说是diffuse对吧
咱们是不是就这两个问题要解决吧
那解决的思路自然而然就是p r t precomputed
radiance transfer啊
这个意思
然后呢呃precomputer radiance transfer
这里面我现在先说清楚
它能够从这个环境光中
然后对任何的b r d f的这个物体
然后考虑他们的阴影
也就是他们遮挡关系都可以考虑进去好吧
然后呃
但是它不仅仅可以用于做这么一个环境光照下
做shadow和shai shading这么上
而他仍然可以去做全局光照
那所以说呢咱们就在这里说
他我觉得再合适不过了
正好那咱们先说了环境光照要怎么做
然后我们通过它
然后再引入呃
后续的这个整个的global elimination怎么做好吧
然后同样道理
我这里再提醒大家一下对吧
听起来不错嘛对吧
p r t哈哈哈哈
听起来不错
但是它的代价是什么
这就是咱们要关注的事情
那么剩下的这一部分呢
ppt这里着重特别感谢一下我的另外一位导师啊
就是我在清华的时候
我还是本科生的时候
带我算是rendering入门的呃
徐坤老师啊
然后人非常厉害
然后是标准的这块t r t的呃
专家哈
然后非常厉害非常厉害
然后所以说这里我就直接用呃
当年我上过的课的嗯
p p t好吧
那就是呃大家可以看一看这个事儿呃
应该很快可以讲完啊
同学们是这么个意思
就是说p r t本身
他们他他这个本身涉及到的知识
真的一点儿也不难
之前的人们人们会觉得它比较难
是因为这个奇函数啊
这些东西反而它涉及的东西多一些嘛对吧
然后但是咱们刚才花了这个时间
把这记函数给说清楚了
然后这样一来呢
用基函数来解决这个p r t这么一个问题
其实也非常简单的事
那咱们来看这个呃
分析啊
还是一样
我们我们之前说在实时渲染中间
人们更愿意把这个rendering equation
写成这么一个形式
什么的形式呢
所谓triple product的形式
lighting下visibility
像b2 d f项
然后这三块乘起来积分
这就是火药的结果
这就是呃任意一个呃呃我我看过去的方向吧
这个看观察的方向
这o这个方向
然后呃我最后看到的一个结果
这么一个值是多少对吧
然后就是这么一个一个思路
那如果说我要真的要解这个函数
然后当然采样是一个思路了
如果我不采样的话
我就真的我对啊
所有的这些这些这些所谓的可能的光照的方向
也就是incident的方向
我我我都考虑一下
然后呢
我就相当于是我把这个lighting
描述成一个球面函数
大家看到球面函数的cube map描述法对吧
这是lighting是个球面函数
然后visibility也是个球面函数
什么是visibility啊
任何一个shading point往四面八方看
咱们看右下角这个这个这个点哈
咱们看这个点
这个点他往四面八方看的当然是个球面了对吧
然后我们也可以考虑
那就是半球吧对吧
他往下面半球看
看起来完全是黑的嘛
大家可以看到这里对吧
这是我们怎么解释这张图
那他往上面看
那自然是有些地方能看到light
有些地方看不到
什么地方看不到呢
有物体挡着的时候看不到对吧
诶那就是说我这一点往四面弯弯看
看到的visibility要么是零
要么是一嘛
我把它记录成当然也是个球面函数了
对不对
那也是可以描述成这么一个形式的
那么b2 d f也是一个道理了
我这一点大家知道这一点的
b2 d f肯定是个四维的
但是呢我由于是从某个方向看的对吧
我从某个方向看
就等于我告诉这个四维函数
我的这个o这个方向是什么
或者欧米伽o是什么方向
那我这个四维函数
既然说我只知道他的观察方向
那么它的入射方向呢
自然就是另外的二维的东西了
就是这个意思了
所以说它也可以描述成为一个呃
二维的一个球面函数好了
那这三项全部都是球面函数对吧
那我现在最简单的
或者说最直接的解这么一个积分
最后解出来一个值对吧
这就是我看到那一点的颜色的的方法是什么
那很简单了
就是对应像素我就挨个乘
是不是就ok了对吧
对应的像素
然后我把它三个的值乘起来
然后呢
我再把这每每一个呃乘起来的这么一个结果
我最后呃去去把他们的贡献加起来
当然中间要考虑它的所谓呃呃
这叫什么立体角了对吧
然后就是说算是一个加权的
把这东西都给加起来这么一个思路
ok好
那这就是最最最最直观的一个做法
那么这个做法是不是非常费对吧
大家可以看到说啊
如果说我要描述比如lighting啊
比如描述这些lighting的话呢
我这里呃任何一个点
我都要描述它整个所有不同的方向诶
它的光照是什么
假如说我这张图把它存成呃一个一个呃一一张
有一个某一种封面分辨率的图啊
这里这个分辨率
咱们假设每块这64x64啊
那我总共12356块吧
六块对吧
所以每一个的分辨率6x64x64
那我相当于我每一个shading point
我都要算6x64x64次
这种呃三个值相乘
然后最后我们再把它加起来
就是非常非常麻烦的一个一个事情对吧
那所以说我们自然不想做这个事情对吧
那所以说就之前呃在呃rabbit啊
提出了呃呃spark harmonix之后
然后就有人立刻联想到这么一个事情
诶
我是不是可以利用奇函数的一些基本原理
我先把有一些比较复杂的一些东西啊
先给预计算出来
那这篇paper就足以记入史册的一篇paper啊
就是呃precomputer rings transfer
for什么什么什么什么啊
然后呃如果大家还记得我之前曾经说过对吧
然后之前啊在说render equation的时候
在game jo 00 o说这名字越短是应越大
所以说我其实非常希望这篇paper名字就叫
pre competreading transfer
后面都没必要说嘛
真的就是这个paper已经说的非常诶
就是供电已经非常大了
然后呢他会预计算一些东西
那么他预计算什么
他怎么才能让我算任何一个点的sha呃
呃shadow啊
带着shadow的这个shing结果呃
快对吧
然后就是这么一个思路的啊
为什么说是带shadow
是因为我们现在已经考虑visibility在里面呢
对不对
好嘞
那么大家可以看
那plt的一个基本思想是什么呢
就是说啊大家看这个式子里面
我可以认为我可以认为嗯我整个渲染的时候
我整个场景其他东西都可以不变
我认为整个场景其他东西都可以不变
就只有光照可以发生变化
我可以做这么一个假设
那这个光照发生变化的情况可以是这样的
可以换一种光照
我也可以同一种光照在这个场景中去旋转对吧
这这都可以的
没有问题的对吧
然后就是说如果我做这样一种假设
我是可以认为这这个rendering equation里面
它要积分的地方
现在我不把它看的那么麻烦
我就把它看成两部分
一部分叫lighting
另外一部分它就跟lighting无关的东西
咱们管它叫light transport
就这么一个思路哈
这就是说我对rendering equation的一个
另外的一种理解
就是这个意思
我们之前说拆成三项也好
现在把它拆成两项也好
没关系对吧
我先把它拆成两部分
那么呢呃p r t做了件什么事
p r t呢他把lighting lighting啊
这不是诶四面八方都有吗
不是一个二维的球面函数嘛
咱们才说把lighting呢拆成basis function啊
大家可以看到lighting吗
不是可以表述成诶一系列basis方式
以及他们前面的系数呃
这不乘起来加起来嘛
对不对
这是可以的啊
然后我在预计算的时候
我就可以把这个lighting啊
然后通过这种方式
然后把它给写出来了啊
这么个意思
然后呃嗯就是说pre computer
既然说我假设lighting是在变化的
它可以变化
没问题啊
那其他的东西是不是都是不变的
对于任何一个shading point来说
它的b r d f不变
但整个场景我认为其他地方也不变
然后也就意味着他light transport
对于任何一个点来说
它是一个固定的一个东西
你可以认为它是等于是任何一个shading point
的自己的性质
这么一个意思哈
那我是不是说light transport我就可以在渲染之前
我先把它给算好啊
这么一个思路啊
这这样就没问题了对吧
如果我假设场景中
只有光照条件可能会发生变化
其他东西都不变
那么任何一个shining point
它对应的light transport的部分
我就可以先把它预计算一下
那么预计算下来是个什么东西呢
大家可以看一下啊
visibility是这一点
我往任意不同方向上去看
那就是不同方向的函数了
球面函数对吧
对于任何一个i它有一个不同的值对吧
方向i有不同的值
这是桥面函数b2 d f
哎既然说我固定了这么一个观察的视角
这个o啊定下来定下来这个o之后呢
哎我就发现b2 d f原本四维的入射光
出热光
我现在出射光
我我观察方向定的那就是二维的
没问题
后面这个n点成这个i n呢
对于这个点来说
它是它是一个这个点的性质
n可以认为是长值
那么这个也是一个i的一个函数
就是cos a项也是a的一个函数
所以总体它们几个放在一块儿
他们本身还是个球面函数啊
这么个意思
也就是说对于任何一个呃
任何一个shading point
他的light transport
如果我还是一样哈
我始终在强调这么一件事
场景中其他所有东西都不变
就只有lighting可以发生变化啊
就是这个意思
在这种情况下
它的light transport就是个球面函数
所以我light transport
是不是也可以把它给写成奇函数的表示呢
那就是这么一个思路啊
那咱们说清楚p r t的基本思想
假设场景中只有光照会发生变化
其他地方都可以不变啊
都都都是不变的
然后于是说其他的东西虽然复杂
但我可以在渲染之前先去把它给呃
预计算出来啊
这么个思路
那么我们分一个这个情况来看啊
如果b2 d f是gloy和b2 d f是diffused
来分别来看
那diffuse的情况自然是简单的对吗
diffuse的情况下
b r d f是什么来着
咱们之前上game 101说了对吧
但b2 d f呢它就是一个长指
他竟然一个长值呢
我放心拿出这个积分来跟这一点关系都没有
我说清楚
这里不是一个什么近似啊
这里是标标准准的等式
他b2 d f既然是一个常数的话
diffuse我当然可以它拿出来对吧
把它写成一个肉
不过大家可能更熟悉的是把它写成kd对吧啊
这没关系了
就是它是一个数啊
这个意思嗯好
那么嗯如果是这种情况的话
那么之前我们可以把任何一个光照
我都可以把它写成呃什么呢
就是呃用basics方式
也就是sparmonics啊
描述的这么一个形式对吧
把它写成呃呃某一个系数乘以spamming
然后把这个就全加起来啊
这个意思
那么如果我这样写
写了之后呢
我就等于这个l
是不是现在我可以把它写成这种求和式了
没问题吧
写成求和式之后
我会发现啊
对于任何一个这个i来说啊
啊这样啊中间其实还缺了一块
我把这个求和式带入到这个积分里面
然后我来交换交
在这个积分和求和的一个顺序是这样哈
在微积分里面
咱们经常会探讨说什么时候可以交换这个嗯
求和与积分在图形学里面从不考虑啊
我们认为他一定可以教会啊
当然啊最近在differentiable rendering中间
大家要考虑这个问题
但是行吧
在p r t这个场合下是绝对不需要考虑的啊
是就是说我放心的交换积分与求和
交换积分与求和之后
我就会发现啊
然后我求和了
这不是对i来求和吗
这l i我又可以拿呃
从这个积分里面把它拿出来
对于任何一个积分啊
在这个i的一个限制下
di一个basic的限制下
这个li都认为对积分来说是常数
拿出来了
那这个积分来说
我看积分剩下来的是什么东西啊
积分剩下来的东西大家可以看诶
这个v乘以这个这个cos一下
哎
这不就是light transport吗
哎咱们刚才说了对吧
除了light就是light transport
light transport乘以一个奇函数
把它积分
这是什么东西啊
咱们刚才刚才说了这事儿对吧
这是什么东西
这不就是说light transport
这个球面函数投影到某个basis function上的
这个系数是多少呢
是不是
所以说呢这块我自然是可以预计算的
咱们刚才说了
场景中只有谁发生变化呀
lighting发生变化
其他什么什么东西都没发生变化
那我对应任何一个shading point
我是不是都可以把它投影到任何一个
basis function上面去
没问题吧
那我投影上去之后
这是什么
这是个数对吧
这是个数
也就是说任何一个shading point
他投影到比如说前多少阶的这些s h上
我只用记录那些数就可以了
然后这些既然都是数了啊
然后哎嘿我我在实际上运算的时候
我会发现什么呢
如果给你一个光照
这光照现在已经写成是呃
呃在这个basis function的情况下来描述的
只需要一些系数就可以了
然后呃这这块呢呃light transport
我又已经算了一个他的他的什么呢
这叫呃就是他算出来对应的这么些数吧
就是它预计算出来这么些数
然后我整个要算对于任何一个shading point
他最后的值
我只需要算一个点乘就行了
这是什么
这就是点乘啊
是不是大家可以看到哎
我我这个求和对谁求和
对i求和嘛
然后对于任何一个i我要算一下li乘以ti
这不是给你一个两个向量对吧
给你两个向量逐逐个元素相乘
再把加起来
这可不就是这俩向量的点乘吗
所以说啊
我对于任何一个shading point的计算算什么啊
说清楚算他的shading
我就只需要算一个点乘就好了对吧
那这样一下就就哎非常好了对吧
然后我这里停一下
我要问一下同学们对吧
这个中间听起来已经非常美好了
但是我刚才一直在问代价是什么对吧
代价就是什么呢
大家看到刚才预计算什么来着
预计算light transport对吧
来transport就意味着说我固定了light transport
就意味着哎这light transport里面所有东西都要定
这cos n项自然是他random equation就带了吧
那这个visibility定义意味着什么呀
嗯visibility定下来
就意味着我任何一个shining point往四面八方看
看到所有其他东西遮挡住
light的方式是完全一样的
这就意味着场景是不能动的
没问题吧
这场景中
比如说我把那个椅子什么东西拿走
这就完蛋了
为什么呢
把椅子拿走之后
这个地面上它势必要引起很多的点
它的visibility这么一个球面函数
它要在某些地方发生变化
是不是这个意思
ok没问题吧
是这个意思哈
没问题
然后呢呃这是一方面
另外一方面是什么呢
我light是不是也做了pre computer
我light做了precomputer之后
诶
那我发现那这种情况下
我light把它描述成basis方程了之后
如果说啊我有两张不同的环境光的贴图
一张是在室外的
一张是在室内的
诶
我把室外的那张也算好
预计算好啊
对吧
然后室内的这样也预计算好
算好了之后
他们各自不就对应一个向量吗
就是不同的l i吗
我就可以换光源了
是不是意思意味着光源我是可以切换的
只要这些光源都被预计算过就可以
那么肯定有同学问
那像这种情况下
那我刚才所说的一种情况
他就处理不了什么
处理不了
如果我还是那个光源嗯对吧
就比如说都是室内的
但是呢这个光源本身可以旋转对吧
如果说我这整个整个环境光还是它
但是它可以旋转哎
这种情况下
那还是不太行啊
因为我已经把之前的这个函数
这个呃就是这个光照啊
对应的这个二维函数
给写成这么一个奇函数的描述了
那如果它发生了旋转
不就等于换了一种光源吗
那不是呃不能处理嘛对吧
那这怎么办呢
那就是人们聪明的地方啊
后面就是就是就是说这个问题是可以处理的
就是说对于预计算了的光源
如果我把它投影到vero harmonix上
我是可以立刻得到旋转了之后
它对应的spherical harmonix的系数怎么样变化的
诶
这是special honix的一个性质啊
这么个意思行吧
不管怎么样
也就是说啊
刚才说了
这个预计算
就意味着场景中间的这些物体都不能动
这是非常痛苦的一件事情啊
然后呃嗯ok那那没问题啊
然后自然而然啊
那个时代人们第一选择对吧
然后我要是用奇函数用什么呢
我就用sparmonix
在这里
大家可以看到另外的一种可视化的方式哈
不过没关系
还是那么些函数嘛
对不对好
然后呃这里哦这里有同学啊
我觉得有有个问题我有必要回答一下啊
有同学问旋转光照不会影响v项吗
当然不影响啊
v向是任意一个shading point
往四面八方看那个方向是否能被物体挡住
他跟具体那个地方的光照没关系吧
l跟v两个本来就是拆开的嘛
对吧好吧
那这个事情说明白
那物理遮挡关系变了
有没有办法能解决
能啊
后续的这个pre computation呃
就是有人在致力于研究这些
就是真的有一些物体发生了形变之后
怎么样去解决啊
这个意思
那么spherical harmonix呢有很多不错的性质
咱们待会再说吧
就是说这几个性质非常不错
什么呢
正交性我们刚才说了一个函数
一个奇函数
如果你把这个g函数投影到另一个任意的
另外的奇函数上啊
然后我就会得到得到二零哈哈
就是说b i乘bj积分结果等于零啊
就是这意味着任何两个呃g函数
我可以认为他们是垂直的
垂直就叫正交嘛
两个是一样的啊
然后呢嗯做投影好算
咱们刚才说了
给你任何一个函数
然后呢
他可以把它投影到这个spark harmonix上面去对吧
然后怎么投影
就是把那个函数和呃任何一个奇函数
做一个product integral就可以了
那simple rotation这里是一个我想说的一件事
我刚刚不是在提说哦
我一个预计算好了一个光照
就算我把它旋转一下
它已经变成了另外一个2d的一个一个函数
如果说我要想得到它对应s h上的系数
我还要把它重新投影一遍
而投影一次到到一个解函数上
我就要解一个积分
那是不是非常麻烦的一件事情
对不对
那这个spiral harmonics
就有一个非常不错的性质
它的性质是这样的
我直接给大家结论吧好吧
因为这个说起来就非常数学了好吧
什么性质呢
就是说spherical harmonix是非常支持旋转的
它什么知识旋转呢
大家是这样想哈
我有一个函数任意的一个
比如光照吧
我投影到了一些呃奇函数上面去
然后这个奇函数前面都得到一个对应系数
那我要旋转原始的这个函数
是不是
就相当于是我想旋转它对应的各自的这个呃
这个这个这ical harmonix的基函数是这个意思
我把每一个vip harmonig函数都给旋转了
呃
相同的这种角度
然后我之后得到的那个线性组合
是不是就相当于是诶我原始的那张图呃
它旋转是不是
那我就把什么呢
我就把旋转原图给变成了一个新问题
变换成了一个旋转
任意一个s h basis怎么做这么一个事情对吧
那么这个事情怎么做呢
啊我直接给大家结论
那就是说啊呃s h一个非常非常优秀的性质
我旋转任何一个呃s h basis函数
都就是说啊旋转之后的这个函数
它肯定就不再是basis了对吧
刚才我们说了这basis是什么东西
它是固定的
它连朝向都是固定的对吧
我旋转了任何一个s h basis之后
它的好性质是这样的
他都可以背同阶的s h嗯
基函数的线性组合得到
ok
也就是说咱们如果回到之前的那么一幅图上啊
在哪呢
这o就是说回到这张图上
如果说我把这个l等于3m等于-1啊
这么这么一个图
我做任意一种什么样的旋转
把它朝向完全变了啊
然后把它变换了之后
它有一个非常好的性质
就是说我仍然可以用它同阶的
什么叫同接啊
同一行通过这么些还是这么些函数
然后他们的线性组合去描述
这个旋转了之后的奇函数长什么样
那么这就意味着什么呢
这意味着我可以打一张表格呀
我任意一个奇函数s h奇函数怎么样去旋转
旋转了之后
我都可以用同阶的这些这些计数来描述它
那就等于是我旋转
它实际上就相当于我在改这个同阶的这些
既然说我们各自的这些呃系数就这么介绍啊
没问题
所以说我就是想跟大家说一下
s h的一个好性质
它可以允许诶
稍等一下啊
我回到刚才那页上面去找
就是说可以允许一个简单的旋转
那咱们再把这个逻辑理清楚
我想旋转任意的光照
现在呢我就等于是要旋转呃
我用来表示它的所有的s h的奇函数
而任意的一个s h的旋转呃
s h奇函数的旋转
都可以用同阶的s h的线性组合得到
那么最后得到的结果
那么还是立刻就可以得到
我旋转了整个一个光照
这个整个一个emamap之后
然后我得到的就是说我还可以立刻的得到一个
呃s h的另外一种新的线性组合
改他们的系数就好
哎对吧
那所以说呢我就可以把它
这个之前我要打一张表算好就可以了
所以说呢嗯这是一个非常好的一个性质哈
然后这样就意味着什么呢
这样就意味着我在做预计算的时候
然后我虽然说啊原本预计算了整个光照
但这个预计预计算了的光照
它是可以让你旋转的
那就非常好了对吧
我可以任意的旋转这个光照哈
这么个意思啊
然后可以立刻得到不同的这些方向
这个光照经过旋转之后
这个物体的任何一个点
它的shading的这个结果的一个变化啊
好那么嗯嗯basis function
这是用不同的阶数去描述这个原始函数
咱们刚才已经说了对吧
你用钱多少阶对吧
用前多少阶
然后然后我可以去描述这个函数
那当然用的前的前面多少阶
这个阶数越多
我也可以逼近这原始的这个函数
大家可以看原始函数在这
然后我用多少个
这里n呢是表示多少个啊啊s h的basis
那多少阶呢
就意味着这里用的是前两节
这里用前三节前五阶
这里大家看清楚前26阶啊
这个呃函数去描述整个的一个一个呃原始的
这么一张一个emal map对吧
这里发现前26届很多了
这时候恢复效果已经还不错了对吧
还有这么个意思好吧
ok那这就是这么一个呃呃奇函数的呃
基本的一些性质哈
以及这里面还说了这关于这个正交性
正交性
就是说你任意一个奇函数投影到其他奇函数上
结果都是一啊
结果都是零啊
其他奇函数都是零
除非投影发他自己投影
他自己的话
结果就是一大家还是类比x轴y轴轴
z轴x轴投影到x轴结果是多少一对吧
投影到其他任何种零啊
这个意思啊
所以呃说呃s h是是一组正交基啊
就是这么个意思好的
那么嗯就是说啊刚才的这么一套思路啊
把任何一个光照写成预计算的形式
然后呢呃就是说我的原本的这么一个光照
现在就可以拿一堆系数来描述了对吧
这堆系数把它排成一行不就变成一个向量了吗
所以光照就变成了一个向量对吧
然后呃这个向量怎么求的
咱们刚才说过对吧
他就是算一个对任何一个奇函数的积分啊
这个product integral嘛对吧
然后最后我要想恢复出来原始的这个图怎么做
那自然而然就是我把之前的这个投影出来
这些系数乘以对应的计函数啊
加起来可以了
好吧好嘞
那么嗯之前还说了这个pre computer的话
把这块light transport也给嗯预计算了
比如说咱们看这么个人头啊
这么个意思
然后呃基本上来说这样一来呃
我的呃这这叫什么呢
就是说呃light transport
我把它投影到任何的奇函数上去
我可以得到这么一个值
是这么个意思
然后其实说白了这就好像是说什么
这里算是一个相对来说比较高阶的一个理解
这就好像是说你在用一个啊
什么样的光照来来这个呃去计算这么一个物体
他在任何一个点
它的shading的值是多少呢
就是说你就相当于是用了一个这么一个basis function
所描述的环境光照去照亮这个物体
然后这个物体各个点上不同的这个
最后照亮的结果是什么
然后我预计算就是对于每一个这样的basis
对于每一个shading point算一个
他最后的这看起来结果是什么啊
这是另外一种理解方式啊
大家看这里不就相当于一个render equation
把l换成了b嘛
就好像是说呃环境光变成了奇函数本身而已
这是另外一种理解方式了哈
没什么问题啊
ok那呃咱们刚才说实际上运算来说
对于任何一个shading point
再算他的shading
就只需要一个lighting the vector和来transport the vector
两者的点称
那咱们这就来把这么一个呃呃pre computation
这就差不多就说明白了
还是这个意思啊
ok嗯嗯行吧
那这样一来大家可以看到一个最大的好处
那对于任何一个shading point来说
我我我要最后算他的结果
我只需要算一个点称
那是非常非常快
然后结果呢自然非常高质量啊
另外是这样
我们说高质量
咱们得看时代
那个时代是2000年刚多一点吧
2002年对吧
然后那个时代能够得到这么一个
在整个全局光照下面啊
全局光照环境光照下了一个结果
那是非常好的
然后呢呃你在算light transport的时候
带上这visibility
像那自然而然可以得到有阴影的结果
那之前如果我们只考虑这shab
就不考虑这个bt项
那得到就是这样的
那当然人们就会喜欢这个有shadow的楼
并且这里shadow加英特尔是什么意思呢
就是说我在算预计算的时候呀
这个呃嗯这块
其实因为我们后续没有说
这个格罗布与伦比的一生怎么算
我们这样想
就除了这这lighting之外
任何的light transport
light transport呀
它不仅是说我可以考虑当前这一个bounce的light
穿错了
我可以认为light还可以在bs多次
也就是说我在假设这个场景中
其他物体什么东西啊
它们形状都不发生改变的情况下
我甚至可以把多次light的多次bounce给它
当成一种所谓的light transport的方式
然后我把它给预计算下来
那同样的道理
我要把它预计算下来的话
那就等于是我可以引入light的多次的bus
那这里大家又可以看到
有一些有一些这些shadow对吧
又有一些这些多次bs造成的
这些shadow就不再那么明显了
当然这个看起来就非常自然对吧
就这么个意思
那具体怎么做
咱们这里就不再多说了
好吧嗯那行
那今天来说我们就给大家说到
这就是关于呃diffuse这块
然后嗯嗯咱们还是说清楚啊
是这样
p r t咱们刚才说他解决两个问题对吧
第一呢visibility已经可以考虑进来了对吧
然后呢呃我说他还可以支持它
不只是defuse的物体表面
但是我们这里只给大家举个例子
说diffuse的情况下是怎么做的
当然b2 d f是个常数嘛
对吧
咱们刚才是这么一个思路
那么如果b2 d f它不是defuse
怎么办呢
那就咱们留到下一节课刚开始的时候
给大家说好吧
那这就说到这儿
咱们今天就讲到这儿
这样的话啊
这样哈
首先呢嗯同学们有什么问题
这里说一下啊
实际上gloy这里还是别说了
gloy得多花一点时间哈
而且而且嗯我怕这样一来呢
跟着diffuse
大家这理解就冲突了
咱们下节课再再说
应该问题不大啊
这个意思啊
ok啊行啊
ok呃下节课我们会说什么呢对吧
我们precomputer花点时间把最后一点完结掉啊
gloss这一块
然后我们还要分析一下
就是说这glossy这块
这为什么会比diffuse要复杂啊
这个事儿嗯
嗯以及相当于是我在gloss的情况下
我如果还想旋转视角啊
或者说这个物体本身还支持它的旋转
这要怎么算
所以东西还是挺多的
咱们尽量这时候就不再不再说完了
那么下节课来说
我们继续呃把这个话题啊
呃给给推向更复杂一点的地方
就是说我们不只考虑环境光照
我们还要考虑实施这种全局光照
然后就是说多次的boss怎么样去解决啊
这时候就到了之前说的3d的空间和屏幕空间
怎么样来解决这个事
好吧行啊呃
ok是啊
真的哈
今天讲的东西已经挺困难的了
然后大家好好嗯对回去消化一下吧
然后之后我们回来再说啊
glossy glossy不好就真的不好做好吧
嗯作业二什么时候出
那就是我是这么假设的
就是说尽量是我回来那周咱们就可以出
然后甚至在我呃我们在讲下节课的时候
下节课之前啊
另外下一个作业就是关于p2 t的
然后呃呃关于这些什么预计算什么东西呢
我们的助教都给大家提供足够的便利
然后大家不用担心说什么
我怎么把这cpu预计算的东西
然后再拿到是什么web记好里面去
这些东西怎么用好这些
大家不用担心我们你这就开始设计这个事儿
好吧嗯
ok然后有同学问我看一下啊
shadow怎么做的
等一下啊
同学shadow不是已经做掉了吗
shadow不就是考虑任何一个shading point
他的visibility吗
这不就是shado对吧
这个意思
ok然后作啊
作业刚才说了
随时间变化程序纹理的环境光不是没法哦
说的太对了
像这种变化的这种呃环境光
这个意思啊
处理效率提高了多少
提高了超级多倍数啊
当时如果诶对同学
你要是还记得说咱们诶202第一节课对吧
我们我们不是说了嘛
就是说呃那个时代预计算就已经可以得到
比如什么几百帧每秒
就是那种恐怖的fps
就是因为这个计算量太小了
我算一个点乘
这还得了啊
这个计算量嗯对吧
这是这这是基本上来说那个年代的啊
这种shader这种硬件啊都可以做到几百帧
现在来说可不得上千帧啊
这么个意思哈哈哈
ok啊
好存储开销说得好
这也是下节课我们要说的事
你既然预计算了
那肯定每个shading point要存点东西
那咱们现在来说
每个shading point还只用存储一个向量对吧
一个light transport形成一个向量
那么呃这个还算是可以吧
就是若干个数呗
顶多比如说取前五届s h那就25个数呗
每个点存25个数
我还是行的对吧
这还是可以的
那么如果说我在预计算的东西多点
那就麻烦了对吧
那就是这个事情嗯
预计算方式能不能做天气系统
有同学说那应该就是什么日出日落呀
然后各种各样不同的天气
晴天阴天呢
呃free computer能做这个吗
呃呃也许可以不computer一部分
我我我我那个一下吧
我回去想一想吧好吧
然后但正常情况游戏中目前来说
大家嗯汇率计算一部分
然后但但不是说像我们说的这种方式
完全都给算进去啊
这个意思呃
有同学问这个real time restring普及之后
p r t要不要淘汰
咱们课前不是刚刚说嘛
呃我认为不会
我认为反而会让prt这块
有一些更多的这些表现啊
这个意思啊
ok啊
每个点的visibility怎么求
面函数怎么得到的
那就从任意点
咱们就假设最暴力的方法
就往任意不同的方向去去trace光线呗
因为是预计算嘛
这块时间你认为可以是呃无穷多了吧
任意一个shading point
往任意一个方向看一眼是不是被挡住
不就行了嘛
对吧哈哈哈
环境光照和ji有关吗
没关系
环境光照是直接光照啊
对不对
光线弹射一次呀
不管它的光线来自哪个方向
弹到物体就被你看见了嘛对吧
这个意思啊好啊
p r t怎么和retraining结合
问题太大了
这个问题我不太能好回答
然后之后再看吧
看research上有没有什么进展
之后再给大家说吧好吧
然后非常好
有同学说理解成是编译时间的开销
然后减少运行时
对了没问题
咱们之前就说了嘛
pre computer嘛
把大量的时间咱们的第一节课就说了对吧
然后大量的这些花的时间咱们放到渲染之前
使得我渲染的时候可以有个非常好的效率啊
这个意思行吧
那今天我就说到这儿啊
然后呃感谢同学们
那照这样来说
那就是两周之后我们再见好吗
ok啊行啊
感谢同学们
ok拜拜